a lot of people are wondering these days
whether it's possible to put the word
Islam in the same sentence as democracy
and human right and to tell you the
truth there are not that many examples
to be optimistic about even in a country
like Turkey where they have a guarantee
of the separation of church and state
they are still moving towards an Islamic
theocracy nevertheless there is one
country that is escaping this trend and
that country is Tunisia with
approximately 10 million inhabitants
Tunisia is the cradle of the so-called
Arab Spring you know that phenomena that
started in the winter of 2011 anyway if
this is where everything started more
specifically things started in the city
of City boses things kicked off when a
26 year old fruit seller earned himself
to death as a form of protest in front
of a government building this is how a
revolution spread all across northern
Africa
and from here you probably do know the
rest of the story in Egypt they
overthrew their dictator only them to be
replaced by a man who is probably even
worse Libya is a failed state that has a
high probability of becoming a radical
Islamic country and well Lester says
probably best that we don't talk about
Syria among all of this madness though
Tunisia is an exception after resting
their dictator Abidine Ben Ali Tunisians
wrote a brand new constitution which was
inspired by French law this new text
allows freedom of speech and the freedom
of religion but not only that now 20% of
the country's parliamentary seats
occupied by women this is a very big
achievement if you consider Tunisia
through any other Islamic country this
is why Tunisia has become one of the
main targets of - so far more than 73
people have died in three separate
terrorist attacks and this is what leads
us to many questions can Tunisia and
liberal democracies survive in such a
harsh environment can Tunisia become a
model for neighboring countries will the
European Union help or damage this
democracy well today we are going to
answer all of these questions for you
but first we need to look a bit at the
history of Tunisia
light and shadows of a BBA Ben Ali in
1955 Tunisia got its independence from
France
just like other countries in the region
the republic of tunisia followed the
so-called Arab socialism or pan-arabism
this was an ideological cocktail the
mixed authoritarianism charismatic
leaders a centralized economy and
finally a secular state you might even
say it's an anti-religious state this
ideology became very fashionable in the
area that brought us tyrants such as
Gaddafi in Libya and Nasser in Egypt
in the Keynesian case the man is Manny
you are seeing on the screen now his
name it was happy before Weber in
summary his government was famous for
its corruption in summary his government
was famous for its corruption
clientelism and its systemic
devaluations of the national currency
the dinar it's really no wonder the
economy eventually collapsed and so what
was the outcome well in 1987 president
Borg Revo was at the hospital recovering
from a heart attack it was at this point
that his prime minister Abidine Ben Ali
took his seat June is Ian's called this
event the medical coup d'etat no blood
was spilled and actually there was no
violence whatsoever even when Borg Weber
left the hospital Ben Ali sent into a
luxury mansion with a team of doctors
and nurses to take care of him
[Music]
legend even says that he went to visit
the man often so you can say that this
was a coup d'etat that you can say that
it was one with a lot of love and care
so what did Ben Ali do well during his
mandate he said that he would bring
democracy to Tunisia and while he did
call for election several times the
problem was that in order to run in the
elections you needed the approval of 30
people from the existing government
party this means that in most of the
cases well surprise surprise the only
eligible candidate was one from the
government party
[Music]
thanks to all of this Ben Ali held power
for 23 years 23 years but of course
continued the tradition of corruption
that the Tunisian people have grown used
to but now there is something positive
we should say la mr. Ben Ali and that is
his economic magnitude from the start of
his rule he encouraged foreign
investment in this encouraged a lot of
foreign companies to establish
themselves in Tunisia this is housed
several hotel chains started up in the
country attracted by the great weather
this led to tourism becoming to Nazir's
main industry followed by the olive
industry and don't forget the latter of
those because we're going to be coming
back to it shortly so during those 20
years humans actually managed to
multiplying their income by 3 in fact in
2010 that unity have boosted over 6
million tourists
[Music]
this is about half the number who
visited neighboring Egypt but do you
keep in mind here that Egypt has well
the pyramids and also a population nine
times the size of Tunisia paying close
attention to the numbers here Tunisia
has a population of 10 million people
and in a single year
they hosted 6 million tourists so why am
i emphasizing this quite so much
well that's because tourists are much
more than an influx of money for the
country they also bring with them
another culture suddenly in a country
which is majority Islam it becomes
normal for people to see women walking
around without scarves on their heads so
I'm a sexual people to be seen kissing
in the streets and for people to be
drinking alcohol there is no other
Islamic country that is quite so exposed
to this level of Western culture so if
you are one of those British people who
got drunken age unity and hotel well
know that you're doing your part for
Tunisia's cultural diversity well thanks
to this wider cultural exposure
something quite extraordinary happened
this democratic transition in Tunisia in
2010 the Tunisian economy was on fire
but the unemployment rate with 12% added
to this work corruption scandals and
power abuses under Ben Ali's regime now
all of these things were of course
hidden from the people in the local
press but due to the large amount of
tourists a lot of foreign media was
being brought into the country and this
educated the people now all of these
things would never be published in the
local press but the foreign media they
were reporting everything and in a
country with so much tourism what is
written outside can very easily be read
inside so people knew what was going on
and they really didn't like it this led
to demonstrations being organized in
several cities perhaps these projects
wouldn't have been so big if it wasn't
for Mohamed Bouazizi it was a 26 year
old man who burned himself to death in
protest after police took over his
Street shop
you
[Music]
this is how the Jasmine Revolution
started all of a sudden thousands of
protesters gathered in every Tunisian
city now unlike other dictators Ben Ali
didn't confront them decently left
Tunisia generally quits after 23 years
in power and leaves Tunisia after this
momentous occasion the presidents of the
Parliament of Tunisia formed a
provisional government and freed over
500 political prisoners not only that
but some Tunisian dissidents who were
living in exile came back to the country
among them the one this man
Montez Mizuki he was the president of
the Arab Commission on Human Rights a
lot of ashoka mukpo sue Roy question you
might wonder now is whether the Tunisia
we're talking Islamic and the answer is
no the Tunisia were talking a team of
private so a year after Boas easily
burned himself to death Tunisia was
holding their first free election and
our friends marzocchi would become the
first president so what exactly wasn't
the problem
well the president was from the Islamist
party
we are talking about the another
movement the Tunisian and perhaps more
moderate version of the Islamic
Brotherhood any time when over 100
political parties appeared in order with
the only one with inefficient structure
this is why the party won the majority
of the seats in the Tunisian Parliament
this is particularly problematic if we
take into account that this was the
party that was going to be responsible
for crafting the new Tunisian
Constitution so you might be wondering
after this how is it that the Tunisian
Constitution that remains so secular
well here's the story
[Music]
after so much political uncertainty the
hardcore Islamists created the so-called
Islamic League these of course supported
the ruling party in order to speed up
the islamification of the country this
led to violence on the streets and even
word and Misha shocked by assassination
opposition leaders Mohamed Brahmi and
Chakri meanwhile the income from tourism
was falling sharply no one wants to
travel to a dangerous country and this
generated more and more social unrest
with this situation the secular parties
created a common front against in order
and this is how the Islamist bloc was
forced to have secular politicians in
their cabinet
months later both the Islamists League's
and the Muslim Brotherhood were
considered terrorist organizations by
the Tunisian government and of course
the most extreme politicians had to
leave the government as well
actually in some month the whole in our
the movement to left the cabinet and
left the decision-making power in the
hands of a secular party
[Music]
they did this with just one condition
and that is that Islam must remain the
official religion in the new
constitution so what was the result of
all of this well the new Tunisian
Constitution is not based on Sharia law
and it includes both freedom of religion
and freedom of speech but not only that
it also guarantees a non-religious
education Islam now holds only a
symbolic position in Tunisia the reality
is that when it comes to politics
Tunisia is a secular nation new free
media organizations were then formed and
what followed this was the creation of
one of the strongest civil societies in
the whole of North Africa after this it
is no surprise that during the elections
in 2014
Islamist parties lost to the secular
liberal coalition now if you still then
believe me about the influence of
tourism in Tunisia well I'll have a look
at this electoral map on this map you
can see how the Islamists lost in the
regions that are closer to the coast and
business because that's where all the
hotels and resorts are but hold on a
second because things are about to get a
little greener who is threatening
Tunisian democracy months after Tunisia
published their constitution - or the
Islamic state organized their first
terrorist attack against the Alvaro
museum this is one of the main tourist
attractions in the country
as a result the number of British
arrivals which look set to break records
in the early months of 2015 has fallen
by ninety three point two percent for
the first five months of this year after
this two attacks followed and in total
73 people were left dead this is why the
Jean is Ian government has a security
crisis as well as an economic crisis and
one of them is destroying their main
industry which is why stories like this
one are quite so important janeshia
to offer fifty billion dollars of
projects to foreign investors not only
that but the European Union has also
eliminated all fares on the import of
Tunisian olive oil as you know in the
European Union agriculture is protected
from foreign markets but in the case of
Tunisia it is essential in order to
support their aulet industry as I said
before it is the second largest industry
in the country behind tourism but hold
on for a moment because as you can
probably imagine this didn't make the
European farmers too happy especially
those ones based in it its favor of
quality say no to Tunisian oil well this
is especially funny given that most of
that oil that is labeled album made in
Italy is actually produced in Tunisia
and then shipped to Italy where it is
labeled and this is where the political
battle starts in in Europe on the one
hand it is crucial to help the Tunisian
economy so they can maintain their
democracy but on the other hand a lot of
European countries don't want to lose
their privileges
so the question is do you think Europe
should open its market to Tunisia do you
think that it is important sacrifice to
make in order to prevent political
unrest in the country and do you think
Tunisia could become a model for
neighboring countries well do let us
know that's what the comments section
below is useful for and of course do not
forget that we upload brand new videos
like this every Monday and every
Thursday so do hit that subscribe button
that is on the screen as well as below
the video to be sure that you are
notified about those videos and also if
you enjoyed this video please do give us
a thumbs up and as always I'll see you
in the next video
[Music]
on the form of lumber